yeah welcome to this video playing oak
from yeah sounds at this South Africa
yeah it is I thought of knew that it is
some some some African state and I got
it right night to detour Wow seems
fairly passive okay we've got a calc on
exchange and night Kid night before I
already's got Bishop b5 check so rather
naive to our to do that who came so who
should I invest one move for age 62 yeah
probably not from I'd edge for so not
such a big threat
yeah it's very similar to the Queens
gambit exchange cards but variation yeah
I can take it I haven't played Queen c7
ok well let's continue hopes access hmm
yeah you're right it's a sort of a
moment maybe I'll blunder blunder the
piece back Queen f6 wasn't exactly a
great start so how to continue now night
h3 is not not so terribly great ever
again i can drop back h4 i give a check
out ticket and take edge form it's not
not a problem and either threat at night
age 32 f form okay so
okay let's make sure that I keep this
night just drop it back to age seven
okay but now I thought I could I could
switch to to a tech mode here mmm and if
not with the move i intended to play
they completely forgot that he can take
it here okay oh this is this is really
enough of course I could have played in
some way to not lose the piece but well
it wasn't exactly a great while I did my
dear now is Queen a 52 h three or maybe
Bishop f4 just keep it simple it's a
pawn and let's really have a terrible
structure well let's get rid of this
stuff and now go to h3
yeah here here king of one yeah let's
let's open up
ok
and i have f 3 end and moves like that
wow what an idiotic game what what the
heck did i do there it was just a clear
piece up for for Christ's sake and now I
stop i'm still playing here okay but if
i take it and play Queen age for Jack I
win this rogue and probably this is
enough now oh he's again giving me the
whom yeah the first one didn't lose the
game at least against my play white yeah
this wasn't exactly a great game of
chess how on earth did a miniature I
just this is stupid I mean just go back
to the eighth enter it's it's not a big
issue but your some of your pieces are
maybe getting lost here no yeah well
thanks thanks for watching thanks for
watching this